vois tu me fait signe oui je commence
par un éclat de rire parce qu'il est
difficile de garder son sérieux quand on
a ses côtés louis de funès lui de funès
a la gentillesse de venir dans les
rendez vous du dimanche aujourd'hui
l'événement de ces derniers jours c'est
la sortie en effet du dernier film de
louis de funès le film de claude zidi
hillel ou la cuisse alors vous êtes
toujours au régime
mais dites-moi louis de funès interprété
dans le film de idy le rôle du directeur
d'un guide gastronomique et être au
régime quelque chose car vous êtes au
régime pendant le tournage et je mange
avec les plats qui passent dans sim sont
des décors non c'était des vrais plats
qui a été fait dans une enchère un grand
entraîneur des plats succulents des
commandes des bides et le steak là avec
de la truffe comment ça s'appelait un
steak and in africa star au sidim énorme
avec de la truffe et puis c'est pas deux
choses il alors pour répéter coluche et
dima faut que je mange un peu sans
saveur à répéter il en a bouffé 3 mai 3
comme ça et moi pour jeux goûter et moi
c'est un petit morceau de pain cégep
endroits touchés se tromper un petit peu
coloré dans la sauce je voulais que ces
banques c'était un petit morceau de pain
ils étaient à peine compétition qui l'a
bouffé 3 machin il a bouffé en russie
les a volés je vous le jure
les enfants il a volé trois gâteaux de
riz comme ça vous savez des grandes
couronnes il est le troisième jeu c'est
pas vrai ils étaient cachés derrière un
décor il le bouffer comme ça trois
gâteaux de riz mais vous aviez
l'entraînement pour résister parce que
vous êtes au régime
nous non parce que je suis sérieux non
j'ai pris ça j'ai pris ça comme ennemi
maintenant j'ai trouvé un système cessé
d ennemi le vin est un ennemi
le tabac tue plus de s'adapter mais le
café ça ne
des fois ça ne me tente plus parce que
j'ai passé quand même deux mois et demi
à l'hôpital necker où j'étais j'ai passé
deux mois dit très bien j'étais très
bien et bien j'avais déjà monsieur de
m'étais déjà des habitués à boire du
café
et comme ça j'ai tenu du coup c'était un
ami maintenant ça continue en plus je
suis très bien c'est délicieux je suis
très triste vous manger le midi en ce
moment les petits hors d'oeuvre les un
tas de choses à capturer des images et
des choses de mon jardin c'est moi qui
les fais toujours biologiquement
cultiver g à bâtir les pommes de terre
et un tas de choses des steaks et
atteint de choses au grill ma fameuse et
des plats délicieux
en faisant de régime votre jardin n'a
pas trop souffert de la sécheresse
sinon non mais j'avais un arroseur mais
j'avais acheté un arroseur américain bb
rue un arroseur qui avance tout seul et
des asperges dont vous avez été
tranquille est alors une fois j'avais
j'arrivais pas d'être marché gt lapuyade
soufflé tout prix que ben alors on
tourne en toute vitesse
mais c'est une chose qui est très j'irai
pas la marque en france et 1 8 finale
vous êtes dans le film de zidi la louve
la cuisse le directeur du guide
gastronomique du ch du chemin bon vous
avez un fils coluche
après ce que vous venez de dire on
imagine comment évoluent dans le film et
que si en dehors du film il ya déjà les
réunionnais aux îles héron dînette
et puis alors il ya aussi un personnage
étonnant dans le film qui est le
directeur d'une chaîne de restaurants il
s'appelle monsieur trika tricatel qui a
joué par guillaume à une des quelque
chose je sais pas
est ce que vous êtes déjà arrêté dans
ses restaurants route dans votre vie
nous pas à pas non non non en france et
des guides gastronomiques vous en avez
failli terre autour de ce film a pas
toujours en avez chez vous quand j'avais
effectué depuis toujours bon nous avons
choisi un extrait du film qui est
irrésistible et je sais qu'il a fait
part j'en suis sûr je suis sûr que les
gens va te plier en deux et on vous
retrouve à l'hôpital
c'est après d'enchaînements on vous
terrassé par une indigestion pourquoi
est ce qui s'est passé mais c'est passé
que le dans le film au début du film je
crois c'est au début il y à un
restaurant qui s'appelle une auberge
sicilienne je crois est le gage du sud
très bien c'est très bon très bon et je
lui mains de ses articles je le cool à
tout jamais voulu enlever ces étoiles
je relève ses étoiles complètement et je
le retrouve trois quatre ans après un
jour où il est maintenant il n'est pas
serveurs bi les cuisiniers il me dit
j'ai perdu mon emploi et je le retrouve
mais vous vous rappelez de mode je veux
pas du tout on voit pas mais si le plu
et ils m'emmènent deux soirées cuisine
avec un fusil et monsieur bouffer tout
le tout ce qu'il a de tout de tout les
escargots puis des explosions qui pue
mls mais il me donne des 18 hrs comme ça
ça va des joutes énorme je paye la
famille je suis celle là je les ai
mangés parce que c'est pas anti régime
ça pèse lourd et il me fait manger ça de
force avec un fusil un tas de choses du
cassoulet ça n'arrête pas le repas n'est
pas un meurtrier après je me retrouve à
l'hôpital
on va de suite l'extrait de ce film et
puis le retrouvons lui de finesse dans
quelques instants
on y continue marcel tu enchaînes
d'accord louis de funès je vous ai déjà
rencontré mais c'est la première fois
que j'ai le plaisir de vous avoir en
face de moi aussi longtemps j'ai
l'impression que vous auriez adoré être
une vedette du muet c'est une époque un
acteur du cinéma me voilà lecteurs parce
que veut dire on vous a fait vous êtes
des lettres parce que l'on rapporte de
l'argent c'est maintenant vedette c'est
un nous s'il ya des grandes vedettes
alors mais les grandes vedettes
américaines du star system que j'adore
je vous ai du star system non mais c'est
pas ça ne devrait pas ça je veux faire
un bon métier très bien un bon acteur et
que moi mais j'aurais bien aimé jouer du
mieux et je dis que les acteur du muet
pu muet ont eu beaucoup de chance ce
soit muet justement il n'y a pas
d'échappatoire du la simplicité de la
lave
c'est une facilité le tarn en le pas la
parole mais il était obligé de
s'exprimer et il n'y a rien il ne
pensait pas que cela leur arrive et on
ira manger ce sera très bon ces saveurs
majeur alors qu'au lieu de nous amener
les pissenlits épices add on fait le
geste qu il avait obligé de faire
beaucoup plus mais en mieux et ils ont
eu beaucoup de chance et mel brooks et
les raisons de refaire un film et moi je
je pensais il ya un ou deux mois mais on
pourrait refaire du film muet même pas
volontairement mua attention du film où
la parole est un petit peu bannie où on
a besoin que une ou deux parole juste ce
qu'il faut mais par exemple je parle
avec quelqu'un mais il ya des bruits de
voitures de on entend pas on ne peut pas
attendre qu'il ya du bruit à côté mais
on
dis quand même quelque chose il faut
donner le comprendre et quand vous lisez
un dialogue inscrits vous dis tiens ça
je pourrais peut-être le faire sans son
texte
oui mais en général le metteur en scène
il faut qu'on dise son texte et puis
l'autre aussi possible de textes souvent
très efficace et du bronze c'est de l'or
alors le large 4 il le coupe toujours
mais toujours dit non non non rires vous
savez il y en a qui me dit oh non je
trouve ça bien
il est allé là bas si c'est joli il est
allé là bas je dirais bien je veux dire
bah lui les pas de nom il est allé
là-bas à shawville mais c'est le metteur
en scène je vais pas m'engager parce que
je fais maintenant je ne peux plus m'en
gueuler sur ça je meurs de vos mimiques
que célèbre c'est bon regardez-moi
proche-orient pure bombe
oui je sais bien alors ça ça a donné ça
il j'ai rencontré toujours quelqu'un
dans la rue qui disputait quelqu'un est
urgent d'argent dans les gendarmes
plein de choses comme ça c'est devenu
naturel chez vous non non c'est vrai
j'aime bien le monsieur sait peut-être
mal c'est ma nature peut-être nous
origines espagnoles puncheon important
c'est ma nature
louis est ce que vous vous souvenez de
l'époque vous étiez photographe est à la
jst oui on voit j'ai fait un tas de
choses oui tous ces petits métiers mais
ils m'ont beaucoup appris m'ont appris à
avoir des personnages avoir avoir des
patrons moi j'étais employée à ça mais
je connais bien les runs l'ailier les
délais des relations des patrons
employés l'alimentation tout est mal
quand je connais tous à partir et c'est
une richesse que jackie publié malgré
moi les têtes de chef de service vous
avez bien photographié à l'époque un tas
de gens j'ai emmagasiné et ça vient la
demande g7 classé comme dans un
ordinateur ça vient
non à la demande ça vient pas dans la
zone la fin dans la journée des phrases
s'avérer bien des choses
j'ai vu beaucoup de choses est-ce que
vous souvenez de cette époque vous étiez
pianiste nation déjà j'en ai vu alors là
j'en ai vu des gens parce que vous ayez
toute la nuit et toute la nuit
12h12 avec la dernière place que j'ai
fait c'était 5 à jouer à 5h30 alors il
vous
5h30 et puis vous repartirez à leur 5e
ribul matin ils disent que cette
nourrice vous mangez mange avec tout le
monde bonjour à jouer vous mangerez dont
je parle pas si j'avais un autre bar
vous m'avez dit elle avoue le manger
pour manger manger dans le vestiaire
dhabhawi pas du tout alors j'étais le
nez contre les maux retour et de doux et
puis je mangeais avec eux pour garder
les manteaux là vous savez dans le
vestiaire tu as dit ce qu'ils me
donnaient le feu y avait l'impression
qu'ils sont d un petit peu comme ça une
de tester sur moi peut-être je sais pas
mais là où j'en étais je sais pas où en
étais-je vous parliez de bêtises
pianiste quand vous avez joué lundi 12
heures oui 12 heures alors il au niveau
des jeunes et vous êtes nourrir juste
humain j'ai pas très fan encore attachés
manger et ça m'a bien alourdi ça
devenait trop jouer jouer 12 heures 12
heures ça fait long ça fait la petite
aiguille il faut qu'il fasse le tour
complet par la grande et la petite mercy
courbes et et puis j'avais quand même
250 morceaux dans la tête
en face à la et puis à 5h30 alors après
il y avait une chose qui était terrible
alors alors je jouais tout seul alors un
homme alors n attendez je reprends alors
j'ai refusé de 2,2
j'ai mangé une fois la somalie que je
dis non non je mangerai après on sent
beaucoup mieux alors j'ai fait mes 12
heures elle à rangoon la ddt funds et
finit 12 heures de piano je suis sorti
c'est ce que je dis c'était erich von
stroheim dans la grande illusion mais
levait tout droit et les traités par
liliane qui n'en est plus très fin j'ai
pu faire ça c'était pas ou quand vous
retournez au jeu pour dormir il y avait
un menuisier qui tapait dans
l'appartement et 6h30 moi qui aime
beaucoup la pêche je partais je voyais
des gars de partir à la pêche société
terrible d'alors je m'installais bayal
et les enfants en afrique commence à se
réveiller pour aller à l'école et quand
il faisait partie des fameux la musique
il commencé dans la cour
c'est là que j'ai appris à me mettre des
boules dans les oreilles et depuis je
vais toujours des coups c'est très
passionnant tout ça mais vous y repensez
de transats à cette annonce et d'époque
je suis très content de l'avoir fait
mais je sais ce que je conseillerai je
conseillerais à des jeunes c'est parce
que j'ai appris j'ai appris c'est vrai
que ce n'était pas la comédie mais si je
jouais déjà dans la comédie ça veut dire
que ça se bousculait pas les contrats ne
vous excusez pas non non vous souvenez
de la première ligne complète de textes
vous a vu dans un film parce que pendant
longtemps c'était des petits mots
c'était vous ouvriez laporte fermé la
porte
je ne parle même pas même pas même temps
pas de texte c'était avec dans la
traversée de paris s'est jamais un rôle
déjà il existerait un petit peu ma force
et avec gabin il m'avait dit vous nous
faire un prix vous savez pas regarder
vous gagnez je ne sais pas le gagner des
missions par jour
mais hier j'ai dit hier j'étais là non
y'a vous étiez à côté de l'appareil vous
lui donniez la réplique à varier n'était
pas dans l'image leur faut faire 5000 a
voulu que je dis c'est mal mais vous lui
parlez alors prenez chaplin ou à l'ailé
très bien qu'elle ne parle pas du tout
prêt d'égaliser qui avait pas parlé
louis il ya un an et demi deux ans pour
vous était fini de cinéma les plus
question d'y penser maintenant ça repart
vous avez l'impression de redémarrer
complètement peu à vous étiez de
repartir sur une base très nouvelle avec
un esprit très nouveau donc
dans le comique dans la manière de le
jouer parce que je ne peux plus faire de
brutalités et c'est tant mieux parce que
c'était cette brutalité ses colères
c'est un produit
j'avais fabriqué un produit et tout le
monde m'a demandé que de ce produit là
les mettre en scène tout le monde
voulait ce nom est énervé toi toi et
appuie dessus alors si je voulais faire
un peu de dentelle pas de dentelle vous
êtes mois que les roms maintenant
a priori non puisque comique ça ne
m'intéresse plus et je prends dans
l'aisne la cuisse justement j'ai joué
paraît-il
j'ai joué tout à fait autrement et je
crois que c'est aussi efficace à des
plus et ben les spectateurs qui vont et
je sais se presser se presse déjà pour
vous voir en jugeront l'ale ou la cuisse
le dernier claude zidi avec louis de
funès avec coluche est connue je veux
leur de gâteaux merci
ça s'est bien passé j'ai filmé c'est le
seul passage qui va hériter du film mais
c'est tout l'écoutant avec halimi nom
des plans de coupe il faut pas parler
mars n avons pas pu écouter mais qui
arrive au tessin
je vais depuis annoncé le patron à
chaque table jane rhodes
g
non c'est pas moi qui vais m'en vais